peut-être pour pour clore définitivement
ce sujet là c'est bien parce que je
reviens sur ce que j'évoquais il y a
quelques instants nous sommes évidemment
ouverts et et partisans du pluralisme
qu'il n'y avait pas une définition
claire en disant alors
promouvoir les la défense de la
République à condition que non c'est
justement l'idée c'était de garder cet
état d'esprit qui d'ailleurs est
caractérise l'appel à projet c'est
vraiment l'idée encore une fois de faire
émerger de nouveaux acteurs de faire en
sorte que des nouvelles méthodes de
travail des innovations puissent émerger
à l'occasion de ce cadre-là
contrairement à la commande publique qui
elle précise comme vous le savez
pertinemment le cadre très exact très
précis l'idée c'est d'aller jusqu'au
bout la logique d'un appel à projet
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que ce format là était pertinent
permettant justement d'ouvrir finalement
tous les possibles le champ de tous les
possibles la seule limite que on a fixé
collectivement c'était l'idée
de s'inscrire dans la conception que
nous nous faisons de la République et sa
défense sans avoir une définition
extrêmement clair précise on peut le
faire mais c'était pas l'objectif donc
l'idée justement et je peux vous
garantir allons jusqu'au bout et
peut-être il y en a là-dessus je pense
que si vous avez fait et plus chez
toutes les associations qui ont été
lauréate de ce fond Marianne il y a
objectivement un prisme assez large en
termes de vision de définition
au sens politique mais non partisan du
terme c'est que il y a des visions très
différentes il y a des histoires très
différentes des trajectoires très
différentes et c'est bien la preuve que
ce pluralisme a été respecté dans le
cadre de cet appel à projet